Brad vs Logan who wins yo Brown's gonna
flame me if I don't say Rod's gonna win
oh in a street fight no in the ring in
the ring in the boxing okay see you made
it harder that's the fight that they're
talking about no no Brad was talking
about street fight like yo I'm 260 pull
up outside the gym I'll rock your
okay who wins in the street fight Brad
in the ring Logan
managed to pull that fence out if you're
awesome thank you yeah don't kick me off
frog here Brad
I'm kidding but Brad is like
obscenely strong too he's quick he's
stronger than Chris Bumstead right
they've had sibo on the podcast and Brad
was like yo don't compare our numbers
because it's not fair he'll say Hang on
we're talking about a world champion I
trained with Chris Chris is a and he's
one of those guys that's got big hands
like you dude you've even your hands are
even muscle yeah
um so yeah he is strong but I don't know
I mean Brad better get on that cardio
game if he wants to try and do five or
eight rounds he's strong and he's also
like a weirdly athletic like he can do
like weirdly High Box jobs or like like
I don't know I just
do you think he'd do it do you think he
would actually go for a boxing fight
yeah with Logan
with Logan probably because now Logan
has called him out Brad would look like
uh Bradley would look like a wimp if he
didn't but Logan hasn't said that he'll
do it personally he said he had found
someone for Brad to fight right uh I
didn't know I didn't I didn't dig into
the the specifics of it but I know that
they'd had beef yeah and they had like
Twitter beef which feels old school for
people that are kind of yeah Instagram
and YouTube Stars I seem so high school
a little bit but
I'd love to see that yeah I think it
would be an insanely like good PR for
both of them they both bring clout to
the table like
everybody emojis yeah everybody loves
them equally like different camps love
them equally as well which is
interesting
what's your what do you went to the Jake
Paul fight yeah for the week what do you
make of this world of would uh Bryce
just won a bare knuckle fight that was
crazy the first thing that I've ever the
first uh situation I've ever seen Bryce
get into
I didn't even know he's doing bare
knuckle and then he goes up against a
guy who's been doing a good a good bit
and wins yeah the wins I think he
technically wants you to do an injury
but he went yeah he won but he called it
too Bryce was like I'm gonna win in
round two and he won in round two
if I play
would you do you want to step in the
ring bare Knuckles no just boxing
I would do boxing I'd fight someone
who'd you wanna who'd you wanna fight
who'd you hate
there's no have any enemies there's no
one that I hate per se there's been
people I think that have hated me
who's your biggest beef been with
I haven't personally had beef who's
beefed with you the most who's beefed
with me yeah
I don't know if I can I don't know I
don't want to bring attention to her go
bro I'm telling you right now I would
cut down to her weight and I'd beat the
out of her
no I'm kidding but I think that um I
would definitely I think it'd be dope to
do like an influencer boxing type thing
like people who haven't fought before
getting in the ring same weight class
you know both had three months six
months training leading up to the fight
and then fighting each other yeah that'd
be dope it doesn't have to be a married
Knuckles like little boxing and it's so
funny how the world of Combat Sports now
has really been reshaped by it right so
you've got Francis and ganu and Tyson
Fury fighting each other you know UFC
Legend up against the greatest living
heavyweight fighter potentially the
greatest ever and I don't think that
that would have happened had KSI Logan
Paul not happened yeah had uh Mayweather
McGregor not happened and if you track
it all the way back it's two British
guys forever ever ever ever ago like
yeah seven or eight years ago or
something that that kicked it all off
and now you've got
who's Logan's next fight Dylan danis
yeah and then KSI is fighting
some guy I don't know he's like big big
time but I don't know
point being
before it was we can't believe that
these influences are coming in and
ruining the sweet science of boxing yeah
and now Downstream the purest boxing
people uh following the model fighting
the influencers precisely correct right
so funny because I think that at the end
it's a win-win for everyone because more
you know the influencers bring a little
bit a different crowd the younger crowd
they bring a little bit more PR to it
whatever it might be I think they bring
a different audience to it that you know
helps them both sells tickets gets
pay-per-view watches
It's Entertainment as well yeah it's
entertainment and
you know when people say this is getting
like WWE and they're talking about
baseball or they're talking about NFL or
whatever NBA
I realized this the other week what they
mean is what happened was WWE
essentially took the sport element out
of sport
and all that you had to do was reverse
engineer the best way to create the
Rivalry and then we'll you don't need to
worry about the outcome of the contest
because we already know what's going to
happen because we can write that right
so when people say this is becoming like
WWE what they mean is they found the
model of how to create a rivalry and
this rivalry is starting to look like
that so really all it is is these people
in NBA or whatever
zeroing in on a really really heated
rivalry that compels people I don't
think it's fair necessarily to say this
is becoming like WWE they split tested
for you know decades and decades the
best oh we're gonna have the heel we're
gonna have like the redneck guy we're
gonna have the clean-cut heartthrob
we're gonna have the Renegade artist
we're gonna have the Mexican dude that's
got the Hat the face mask on yes yes
yeah this episode is brought to you by
levels one of the single biggest
predictors of how long you live and how
good you'll feel while living is your
metabolic Health the single best way to
work out how your daily decisions are
impacting your longevity and Your
vitality is by tracking your glucose
this is why I wear a continuous glucose
monitor from levels it allows me to
understand in real time how the foods
that I'm eating are impacting my health
and the way that I feel the levels app
interprets your glucose data and gives
you a score after each meal so that you
can see how different meals are
impacting you and it will give you
personalized diet recommendations that
are right for your body glucose is a
huge determinant of not only Your
vitality and your longevity but of the
way that you feel day to day using
levels means that you take the guesswork
out of this it can help you to nudge
your diet towards something which is
going to be better for you right now and
in the long term as well after using
levels I realized if I have a large carb
meal and I do not go for a walk
afterwards my blood glucose goes through
the roof and I don't feel so good head
to levels.link slash modern wisdom to
take advantage of an exclusive offer
plus get that 90-day money-back
guarantee that's levels dot link slash
modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Sarah then press here for the full
length episode go on press it